and you know your kids and your
grandkids will probably be poor or very
poor that's the way this country is
going right and i think if older people
knew that
they wouldn't accept it so on the one
hand like i totally understand that
what we are building here is a system
which hits the youngest worse and
protects often old but you need to add
look there's a lot of very poor old
people in this country so we shouldn't
we shouldn't be just like
young old you know what i mean um but
not only that like if we allow that to
become a division and especially if we
allow likes to some degree of hatred to
fester in that division if we allow
young people to get angry and to hate
the old then that will become a division
which prevents
all of the
ordinary people of this country from
coming together to push me back and i
think that that is what that is what the
billionaires want right they want us to
fight each other and be angry at each
other because if we were not angry at
each other then we would point at the
true villains here who are destroying
our lives and our economy which is the
super rich